from the New York Post because this
one's got big implications for 2024 a a
top strategist for JP Morgan predicts
that Joe Biden will drop out of the 2024
race in March and I agree I believe uh
that there's a strong likelihood that
Joe Biden will drop out and it all makes
a lot of sense now when we were talking
about Nome this is last year we're like
Newsome's probably going to be the guy
Joe Biden drops out a bunch of people
Super Chat into the show saying it's too
late Tim they can't hold a primary now
so it's Biden or no one wrong this is
the perfect play Joe Biden stays in and
then through no fault of his own oh no a
medical issue oh he's having heart
murmur or something he can drop out then
the DNC says well this is a catastrophe
for us I mean what do we do it's too
late to have a primary guest will have
to just appoint a nominee sorry
progressives no Bernie Sanders for you
no Jen yuger no RFK Jr it's going to
have to be Gavin Newsome or Big Mike yes
Michelle
Obama I mean I think that's a big
possibility I think Michelle would win I
mean I think there I mean I think I
would have thought so a year ago I'm not
so sure today not anymore no no because
Trump's winning among the in the youth
vote in numerous po jtim this is like
you actually have faith in the election
process I mean I I know we can only say
so much on YouTube but I mean no YouTube
allows you to say the election I know
you can now but I still don't like
messing with the terms of service I just
I I just really have such little faith
in our future election and I think if
they take him off the ballot Trump lost
by only what like 44,000 or something
there was like three states you know
like 11,000 votes in each state or some
exactly so if you if you think that for
all of their efforts that's the margin
they won by and now with Trump the polls
are inverted Trump was down in the polls
and and got and and only lost by like
40K votes imagine where he's going to be
now I mean they could like they can try
and cheat all they want and they're
going to and it's going to be
embarrassing for them they're not going
to have have the same level of bout
harvesting to to assist Joe Biden they
would have to go fullscale fraud to try
and cheat this gu did you know this stat
from the past election Donald Trump won
every single state from their inperson
voting Joe Biden won every single state
with mailin voting for the first time
yes he even won The Bluest States in MA
in inperson voting Trump did wow yes yes
and the uh bellweather counties that
typically always have been always
correct this time we all completely
wrong except for one and just the energy
he had compared to Joe Biden there' be
like four people at the Biden rally well
and Biden didn't go anywhere he was like
basically campaigning from his house
that's what I mean there were like four
housekeepers in his basement yeah it's
like all of his kids and grandkids are
hostage I think the bulk of what worked
for Democrats was ballot harvesting yep
you combine ballot harvesting with lax
signature verification what do you get a
guy go election in history Tim how dare
you oh sure a guy goes to a nursing home
and then says I'm here to collect Bel
for I'm here to make sure everyone voted
then goes to all these old people and
says just check this box and now sign it
and all these signatures are wacky
because these these older people have no
idea what's going on and then signature
verification was way LAX in many of
these places and even then Trump still
only lost by like 50 or so thousand
votes you take a look at uh uh the Trump
campaign put out a b a big list of all
the states where they think that he
should have won and the margins are
microscopic 10,000 here 3,000 there with
Trump's polling today with numerous
polls showing that he's he's uh uh he's
beating Joe Biden in the youth vote the
Democrats absolutely must remove Joe
Biden and bring in Gavin Newsome or
Michelle Obama because if Joe Biden runs
and they keep him in and they do not
remove him from the from the nomination
or from from from the candidacy Trump
wins their only play is going to be Joe
Biden you are out someone else comes in
do you think Nome has enough support
among young progress Rives sometimes I
feel like they are not they are not
willing to have another white male be
the leader of their party and
that I'll tell everybody right now right
now in 2020 everyone says Trump had all
the energy and
enthusiasm but Joe bid because Joe Biden
had no favorability like no no
enthusiasm the polling was like 20
something perent 24 26 Trump's was like
90 enthusiasm against Trump to oppose
him was higher than enthusiasm for Trump
creating a big opportunity so I will
tell you this right now the polls show
that if it's Trump V Biden Trump crushes
Biden in every way but they also say
Trump versus anyone else and he loses by
a little bit we will see considering the
polls were heavily against Trump and
he's still only lost by like 44k votes
even if the polls are saying Trump's at
you know 49 to other candidates 50 or
whatever it's still indicative of a
trump victory
I do think however the most important
thing imaginable is everybody's got to
go campaign you got to knock on doors
you got to register people to vote you
got to follow Scott Pressler on Twitter
and just when he says here's how we
register people here's how we get them
to vote that's what you got to do and
you got to recognize if the Republicans
are not preparing for the law fair it's
already over you've already lost 2024
election well I think Elon must said it
it's like whatever the most entertaining
outcome is probably what's going to
happen and to what you're saying Hannah
is like you'd think that you'd want this
Multicultural progress
you know CA Harris type candidate but I
think that irony they're going to do the
opposite and they get another blue blood
Joe Biden white guy like gome it's like
the opposite of what you expect so
that's why I think that he probably has
a chance but does he have the uh support
behind him no I don't think so that's
the thing like Joe Biden's completely
unpopular everyone thinks he's too old
including every poll that they do do
about him youth vote is not motivated
for him he's not gaining there but they
don't really have anyone else I mean I
don't think they want it to be Biden but
I don't think Michelle would win I don't
think Gavin necessarily holds at least
long term maybe they could sneak through
in kind of a desperate attempt but I
don't know that people actually want him
to be the face of the party right now
they're very divided we saw this with
all of with everything that came out
with um the Israel Hamas conflict I mean
the Democrats had to look themselves in
the eyes and say we are a split party
even though we pretending that we are in
locked up this whole time they're not if
John fedman runs would we vote for John
fedman who's we who I mean would we
would you like a fedman presidency if he
was a democratic nominee I mean what we
do know is if he was running against Dr
Oz the nation would probably pick him
yeah yeah I mean fedman has become sort
of amusing but I wouldn't vote for him
my favorite Democrat probably right yeah
he's he was he was defending Israel and
he called out the Christ on the southern
border so I'm like well you know take
what you can get I guess yeah but maybe
that's the future for a lot of Democrats
I mean we used to say this about Joe
Mansion right he was the last of the
blue dog Democrats he represented a
different time and maybe the fact that
he's leaving the Senate and several
other people are starting to think hey
this party is drifting too far I need to
start tacking back towards what used to
be considered the Middle it's probably
still just the left that's right well
this has happened in the past right so
right after the Reagan Era Democrats
realized that they had to be more
conservative in order to get elected so
when you look at campaign ads from
people like Bill Clinton back in the
early 90s it's a different kind of
democrat who's more moderate and wants
to roll back the welfare state and
that's probably What's Happening Now
Democrats are realizing that they have
to move to the right or at least a
little bit closer to the center on
certain issues because of how far
they've SW to the left and we really saw
this back in 2022 or 2021 with Joe
Biden's State of the Union Address we
watched it on this show and he was
really going on and on with talking
points that were basically lifted from
Trump about how we need to defend the
police and secure the southern border I
I got to push back on what what Alex
said however which is not your quote but
Elon Musk that the most entertaining
outcome you know tends to be likely or
whatever what something like that
something like that yeah like the the
the outcome that's most entertaining is
what's going to happen more likely
something I think that's what it sounds
like it's it's incorrect it's it's a
point to be made that a lot of
entertaining outcomes are happening but
the most entertaining outcome absolutely
not the most entertaining outcome in
this race would be if like tomorrow
someone saw Trump and Biden walking down
the street in DC holding hands and when
they were asked why they're doing it
they explain that they're simply sharing
proteins and he and then he asked
protein strands can you think of a
better way exactly right Simpson's
reference like the most entertaining
outcome would be like of Joe Biden and
Donald Trump playing patty cake in the
White House lawn and us being confused
and just laughing about the absurdity of
it no the reality is it's going to be
likely the most shocking in terms of
entertaining okay maybe this
entertaining maybe is the wrong way to
describe it but perhaps the right word
because you know like die hard is
entertaining which involves a lot of
explosions and people dying yeah well as
you say that I mean what do you think
the possibility is they can't get Trump
off the ballot and I would never want
this to happen obviously but what if
they did a Lee Harvey Oswell type
situation I mean do you think that's
possible in this day and age where there
could be a presidential assassination or
flag false flag just
possible some already tried to take
Trump's life in the in his first run in
it was 2015 I think a guy at a rally
tried grabbing a gun from from a cop I
think it was because he was trying to uh
let's just say seriously hurt Donald
Trump um but I think the
likelihood that there is like a deep
State attempt on the life of the
president you know in any capacity be it
Trump Biden or anybody else is very very
very low yeah what you need is character
disgrace not martyrdom if someone look
we see this all the time with
politicians
assassinations will stop a politician
and immortalize their
ideas and hold on and an assassination
attempt boosts their popularity and
ensures their victory yeah would he what
would his legacy be if he I mean if that
happened would it be positive or
negative for all of the Trump supporters
and for everyone who comes after he
would be he would be a legacy he he he
already is going to be like the the the
the you know who's he's already a murty
no they say who is the who is the heir
of Maga right people are saying V ramas
Swami already Donald Trump is viewed
this way but if if someone were to take
his life all they would do is
dramatically Empower Maga 100 fold yeah
they would so that is not the play and
and I think ultimately More Than You
Know The Enemy you know is better right
like the the Democrats know who to
attack with Trump they kind of know his
weaknesses and they also position him as
the party of the past that's what said
in his first campaign speech right the
Maga party is focused on the past but
we're the future and then spends the
rest of his 30-minute speech saying so
this is what happened three years ago
and why it's bad and all the
repercussions I mean they really want it
to be Trump because they think they know
their enemy and whip up hysteria against
him if if something were to happen to
him an unknown candidate like vake or
someone else would be almost more
challenging and therefore it's bad I
think there's truth in that I'll also
mention this uh because I slightly
disagree with what Tim said I I don't
I'm not making any prediction that Trump
is going to be assassinated that there's
going to be attempt on his life but I
will say they have repeatedly tried to
assassinate his character and it hasn't
worked with his base and it hasn't
worked with a lot of the country and if
anything it's just made people more
skeptical of the media and so at some
point if they're really is a conspiracy
to take a person out you go from trying
to assassinate their character in media
if that doesn't work some kind of
conspiracy to try to imprison them and
if that doesn't work you really only
have one option left even if it is a
thing that'll turn him into a martyr
because what it does is it sends a
message to the next person who might
stand up and run for that position
that they're going to have the same
outcome as the last guy well and you
really think about it though it's just
an illusion that we have that we
actually have choice of right or left
because like I mean let's say it is not
Trump let's say they kick him off the
ballot then we have listen I like some
of what Dan santis did in Florida but I
mean Nikki Haley who's being so propped
up by The Establishment even just said
that the illegal immigrants across the
border aren't criminals I mean so that's
right that offensive to call them that
that's what she just said so it's like
give me a break that you think Nikki
Haley is all of a sudden I mean we don't
have anybody on the right that's really
going to be our savior and that's why we
say this on the show all the time it's
idolizing a politician it's like
thinking the stripper actually likes you
you know we just it's all a facade it's
all fake I I trust V yeah I like no I do
too I trust yeah I will say I trust
Trump to be Trump I have trust in V but
let me clarify that doesn't mean that I
trust him absolutely 51% you know what I
mean like we'll see what he can do he's
just some guy talking to us right now
I'll say this well uh back when when Tim
was gone for a week and I had the honor
of of Hosting shim cast for a week for
wor was the worst week of the show ever
without question it was awful we bombed
in the ratings and everyone hates me
super chats were way down don't forget
how low super super low but one one
advantage was I also made V hate me cuz
he had to sit through a two-hour
interview with me but through that
two-hour interview I was really I mean I
did no I really appreciated his answers
I he wasn't just giving me political
talking points he went very deep on the
issues he was talking about things like
how Duties are are are or I'm sorry how
rights are a product of Duty and not the
other way around I was like that's like
I say that all the time um and I really
appreciated the fact that he had a very
thought out worldview on the philosophy
rather than just a series of policy
positions because someone who's really
thought out about their philosophy who
genuinely wants to bring those ideals to
fruition in the real world they're going
to be a lot harder to get to flip-flop
on certain issues because it's now it's
not just like a platform of issues that
you can kind of compromise on it's a
whole entire worldview that you're going
to want to hold to and that you're going
to want to represent honestly and they
have a way to navigate challenges they
don't have to have they have they have a
a framework from which they can make
ethical decisions I mean the is a really
interesting guy you know I've said this
a couple times if he is you know not the
VP or whatever I would love to see him
run in Ohio because I think he is the
kind of person who could breathe energy
into you know a state that for for all
intensive person needs a little bit of
of boost I mean it's a it's a very nice
state but you know there's not a ton of
Industry there as far as I know there
isn't a ton of young people moving in
and staying there it could use strong
leadership and so I think with vake
there is a chance that he is able to do
something on a small scale and then
potentially in 2028 win people over
people who sort of weren't sure he was
on tested quantity he will just lose the
If he if he runs for another office he
does lose the edge of being The Outsider
the non politician but does that matter
if you have a proven track record of
positivity exactly and what he gains is
again the track record and the
experience one thing I think is
hilarious and ridiculous about America
politics is people put so much emphasis
on experience that they are actually
more willing to have someone who has
experience but all of it has been a
complete disaster and they've destroyed
everything they've touched rather than
someone who's an outsider coming in who
has experience in the private sector and
has done tremendous things in the
private sector doing things that are
arguably far more difficult than public
sector work or elected office so people
will go well vake he just doesn't have
the experience in government it's like
okay but a lot of these other people do
have experience in government it's all
awful that in they they've destroyed
everything that they've had the
opportunity to lead the experience they
have is how to exploit yes their
position in government yes and V's
really smart he's married to a surgeon
he was you know he's just a smart guy
independently wealthy and and I think
also one you know and all the staunch
Republicans are going to get mad but
that he did have liberal views and he's
changed his viewpoints at a young age
I'm just saying that's kind of the
ultimate person is that seen both sides
so I I do think that's why he's so
successful too is that he's a disruptor
he's saying hey let's get rid of the FBI
let's get rid of all these alphabet
agencies so I mean he's saying All the
Right Stuff thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net